brian is with us in rochester new york
hey brian welcome to the ramsay show
hey thanks for your wisdom really
appreciate all that you do
our pleasure how can we help so
i'm in kind of a conundrum and i wanted
to get your advice
um
i have about 98 000 in
cash on hand 150 000
in a retirement account 51 years old
i owe 61 000 on my business
mortgage that's
the only debt that i have than a couple
of car loans
and i'm wondering if i should pay off
the
business debt or invest that money
into my retirement i'm afraid that i
just don't have enough
save for retirement what do you make
our bring home is around 75.
okay how long you had the business
too long okay what's that mean
that means 20
uh 29 years i mean too long i mean like
you don't want it anymore what do you
mean
uh well just kind of burned out on it
what are you gonna do with it
um i mean at this point
really my only choices are to either
sell the real estate
and go into other ventures or just
continue
doing what i've been doing and how old
are you
51 what's your business
it's retail what what burned you out
what burned you out
uh just 29 years of doing it and not
being as far as i thought i should be at
this point
the 75 000 year income or is your wife
also work outside the home
that's combined what does she make
right around bringing home is right
around
15. okay so she works part-time
no she's full-time but a lot of the
money goes towards uh
health insurance
okay well there are several things
i'm going to answer several questions
that were not asked
i'm not going to be 51 and be going for
the next 20 years till i'm 71 i'm going
to work a
business that i'm sick of and i don't
make much money at
why would you do that what's the real
estate worth
um probably around 200
yeah i think you'd be better off being a
landlord and get a job
or you'd be better off starting another
venture of some kind like you said
what would you do renting yeah i think i
think you have an
opportunity to rethink things and and
you called in about paying your mortgage
paying you know paying off a debt
but there's a bigger question at play to
your point dave i'm going to answer
questions you didn't ask
i think that the the assumption that you
have to keep doing this and be unhappy
when you're 51 is
is not an accurate assumption they give
an option opportunity to say
what do i want to do with the next 20
years 30 years and
and this is obviously not the path so
what do you want to do well that's going
to help answer the question of what you
do today with your business with your
money
with your debt etc but don't just make a
decision today based on well
i've got this debt i've got this cash i
guess i should pay it off and just keep
plugging along going through the motions
in your life you're not
you're not happy you're not making great
money at it that you
what you want to be doing what you're
proud of what you're excited about you
can hear it in your voice you're not
excited about it so what what would
excite you
what do you what would you do if you
could do something different
so i vent i have uh the money that we've
the 100
000 that we we have cash on hand we've
earned by flipping some houses some real
estate that we've
bought and held and rented and then sold
in an upmarket
and that's what really kind of you know
motivates me kind of that's really where
kind of my heart is cool and i can do
that i can do that anywhere and
and that's the luxury that we have is we
can kind of go
anywhere our house is paid off um
you know some inherently yeah so the the
real estate that's worth 200 000 is that
what the 61 is owed on
yeah okay
all right and the business has
absolutely no value you don't think
um i really i just don't think it does
it's it's retail
um floor covering and
there's you know in in a 30 mile radius
there's probably
20 to 25 different locations yeah but a
competitor wouldn't want another
location in your area
they may buy our vet our customers but
that's about the extent of it i think
yeah
maybe i'm under selling it well make
sure of that before you
yeah before you understand it because
your burnout so you're looking at it
with those eyes you're looking at it
with burnout eyes
there's someone else may look at it and
see i would talk to a competitor under
under a non-disclosure agreement that
says they can't talk about it
but i would talk to a competitor that
you think is a little that's doing well
that is excited in the market and just
say hey if i was to uh
if you if you were to look at this how
would you value it and would you
consider it and let's just let don't you
don't name a price and you don't walk
around with your lip stuck out you say
you know just just poking around here
i'm i'm really not that interested in
selling but i might if the price was
right
and i want to know what you the kind of
number you'd put on it and then maybe
he's going to offer you something that
makes your jaw drop
okay and then sell the real estate and
put 140 000 with your 100 000 and do
flips
i'm having fun though yeah
i mean so my biggest
uh my biggest concern is the lack of um
retirement at 51. you're going to be
fine if you're flipping my if you're
flipping houses and making money you can
invest it
right you got all kinds of time to
invest if you just get with it
but right you know dude you know
truthfully you're just you're you're
burnt up
and just just your voice tone even
it changed when you started talking
about the houses yes the first time the
first time we heard energy in your voice
yes
your voice audibly changed and when you
talked about that
you're right you can hear it and that's
what's gonna that's what's also gonna
fix the retirement thing
it's not it's not slogging it out here
on something now if you were making 250
000
a year on this business and it was going
to take four years to sell it or
something
i'd slow your butt down until you suck
it up and man up and get it done
but this thing you need to roll out of
this in the next six months and you need
to put that commercial property on the
market you need to start flipping houses
and take some of that flip money
and invest it fully fund your retirement
and uh you're gonna have plenty of
retirement and you're gonna make some
money and you're gonna have fun again
that's exactly what i do i pay off the
cars today